eg was on the scene at the 2016 of VMAs  here's a four things that you didn't get  to see on TV Kim Kardashian and Kanye  West or totally the king and a queen of  the night gathering a crowd of fans and  friends around their seats inside Kanye  even got the whole section pumped up for  Rihanna's opening number while Taylor  Swift skipped this year's show her fans  were there in full force chanting her  name during Kanye's free video from your  speech pigtail Taylor dick Rowe like I  love all y'all  that's why I called her Britney Spears  at the VMAs stage for the first time in  nearly a decade and that opening  handshake wasn't a trick at all her  backup dancers were making that happen  live on stage  but no one has shut down the stage a  quite like Beyonce Queen B was the only  star to get the whole crowd up on their  feet  you